[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i said what's your go-to mcdonald's
order mine's very simple but it's uh
it's a big mac meal super sized yeah for
cheeseburgers
now why the four cheeseburgers
mcdonald's cheeseburgers
cheeseburger just a cheese simple
cheeseburger done anywhere is one of my
favorite things but what i do with the
mcdonald's cheeseburger and i'd like to
brag a little bit because i got written
up first of all when you talk about
mcdonald's there's no bragging involved
there should be shame and embarrassment
go on by the way my my whole meal in
total is 2 500 calories that's and that
is my go-to meal burnt chrysler
mcdonald's or a challenge today we're
going to attempt to eat the super-sized
big mac meal and four cheeseburgers
bert's go-to order just for context i'm
6'2 and weigh around 185. bird is a
similar height to me but i think he
weighs closer like 300 or 325 so this
will definitely be a challenge and i'm
excited to see how it goes how can i
help you hi can i get the machine meal
um what do you think the big mac meal
super sized and four cheeseburgers
please
is that a big one meal
yep big mac meal
what drink uh water's fine okay
other than four cheeseburgers
you take four cheeseburger yep
can you say cool for the bigger uh water
okay thank you
thanks jeans
thank you
this is not a water
but i think bert got a coke anyway so i
hate coke i don't like pop i don't like
fizz kind of hurts my mouth thank you
me too
pro tip put your food on the seat and
turn the seat warmer on until you get
home
bert would eat half the food before he
gets home though so i guess that doesn't
matter all right so burt technically
does have some rules about how he likes
to eat the cheeseburgers all right so go
on so then what i do with the mcdonald's
cheeseburgers is i take the bottom bun
off and i taco them so it's less
calories so bottle bottom buns a little
thicker and it's got none of the
business on it wait a minute are you a
third grader like who would do something
like that like what like
you taco them like that is not a thing
it is in a taco style which i've never
done before
let's get everything laid out here
all right i had a few fries in the car i
mean the fries go bad
are you [ __ ] kidding me
they only gave me [ __ ] tissues
oh my god
this is going to be disgusting if i go
get two more
by the time i get back
and i'm starving
so i'm gonna eat this
and then i'm going to go get
the other two burgers and
that's so lame dude oh my god of course
mcdonald's messes up you can
i hate mcdonald's of course they messed
this up dude
that's so frustrating
all right well i gotta think of my plan
here i am gonna go with the taco burgers
first
it's so funny that i have to think of a
strategy to eat this like what i should
eat first and this is just bert's normal
lunch
all right
taco burger number one
i'm so mad
i'm so mad they forgot the other burgers
i can't even enjoy this
no rooms old
video i have to go back
one down
that was easy all right burger number
two
bottom bun off
dude like
what is this
these are easy to eat like this
and you gotta eat the fries soon because
they really gross when they get cold
but
hot dogs fries
with the right amount of salt are the
best fries and fast food
bk worst fries
wendy's
pretty medium
[Music]
mcdonald's cold fries
the worst things you can eat
from the world
i'm done with my cheeseburgers already
[Music]
this is gonna be so easy i think
i know those other two
this is gonna be the hardest part is
finishing this
this coke
all right
big mac
i'm gonna smash the big mac
smash the rest of the fries
and we're gonna go get two more burgers
and eat those this big mac's gonna take
me longer than those small burgers so
feel free to enjoy these clips of bird
talking about how much he loves
mcdonald's while i eat this mcdonald's
in the corner
okay so what's the best thing what's a
cheeseburger just go cheeseburger
burger these are like these are
signature sriracha these are mcdonald's
these are weird what country are you go
this is what vpn are you using
use expressvpn they look better mac is
540 to 560. okay there you go quarter
pounder okay 560. we'll say 560. because
i made sure that all the stuff is in it
and then cheeseburger yeah it's got to
be just a regular
just it's not going to be a double
cheeser because i took they didn't take
them
oh cheap
doubles 390. cheeseburger bacon there it
is 300. fries update the fries are
starting to get that
room temperature soft feel
they're not crispy anymore
starting to remind me of worms
look at the flop on this fry
that's why you gotta eat these hot
i took these all the way home from the
drive-thru sat down turned this camera
on ate two cheeseburgers that was a
mistake
if you try this challenge eat the rice
first there's so many different add-ons
you could do
to a mcdonald's meal like there's a
thing called a
um
a mcgang bang which is a
it's a double cheeseburger type in
gangbang it's a double cheeseburger with
a fish fillet shoved into it so like
there are meals people do you can also
get that's not right
you can get the fish fillet bun
yeah on anything the fish filet bun is
thinner than all the other buns oh i
didn't you can also take the double you
can do any add-ons they'll do anything
for you i cannot believe this is how
much bert eats every time he goes
mcdonald's this is his normal order it's
starting to get hard for me
i only have two burgers
i have this big mac and i'm almost done
with these fries
it's cold ass fries
oh
i'm gonna microwave this [ __ ] bring
in a burger contest right now i could
[ __ ] up some burgers burgers would be
good i bet i could i bet i bet i could
write that down the big mac is so much
bread dude you got the first layer of
bread i'm gonna taco the rest of this
dude
because
there's just too much bread
a quarter pound of cheese tastes better
than a hamburger taste but i remember
being introduced to a quarter pounder
with cheese i remember where i was when
some people know where like where were
you when 9 11 happened you're like i
remember where i was when i was
introduced to gordon panda with cheese
that was terrible
how did he do this
there's a casual lunch dude are you
kidding me
oh
i feel like joey chestnut right now i
didn't even eat the first two hamburgers
this guy goes to mcdonald's normal order
it was a super sized big mac meal
and four cheeseburgers
i remember the day i learned i'm trying
to be healthy tom and i were doing a
weight loss challenge and i took the
bottom bun off the burgers yeah and
realized all the stuff you want to catch
up the cheese yeah all the flavors on
that top bun yeah and nothing's on that
bottom so you do it to kind of remove
some of the carbs yeah move some of the
carbs and then i they got away from me
for a while because i was like well i
normally was gonna eat four burgers now
that i'm doing this i could eat eight
what is this
and he like plays with his food too like
he's making cheeseburger tacos it's all
a joke to you bert this is serious this
is hard to do
okay
finishing the big mac
this is just bread on top of bread
i'll finish the rest of this meat
i'll eat this meat nothing bro pizza
laws
that was really gross
almost got
how about
i need a champ
there's food flying on my mouth right
now isla sees at mcdonald's and she was
like knows liam will not let her get
mcdonald's she goes dad let's can we get
mcdonald's and i go of course so we pull
through mcdonald's i go what are you
guys getting thinking i'm gonna get a
little have a little bit of what they
get you know yeah and eileen goes oh
just a small fry
[Applause]
i'll tell you what
i'm full i thought this was gonna be
easy oh whatever i don't know it's gonna
be easy
i don't think i'm gonna go get the other
two cheeseburgers
there's no one
i need maybe one more
and then i go what do you want george
and she goes small fries i go what the
[ __ ] wrong with you no one gets small
fries so they go can i help you is that
what you said what the [ __ ] wrong with
you yeah you're knowing it's no one goes
to mcdonald's and gets small fries
that's like the dumbest thing i've ever
[ __ ] heard a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that's like people who drink just like
people who drink decaffeinated coffee
what are you just trying to stain your
teeth yeah [ __ ] yeah i don't know
i don't think i'm gonna get them i i'm
so full
i failed the challenge i'm finishing
fries i ate
four cheeseburgers and a big mac on the
ride home and the fries oh the fries
were gone before we left the
drive-through yeah i mean the fries came
in and i [ __ ] waiting for the burgers
i ate them [ __ ] like just fistful
yeah that's the best my normal
mcdonald's order
20 nuggets with barbecue and honey
mustard
and quarter pound with cheese oh good
fries oh i get i get small fry sometimes
i guess that's still
a pretty big order
[Applause]
not like this though dude i cannot
believe every time he goes he's this
full
floss two more burgers
and i drink like none of this
[Music]
ma'am
i'll take one more step with a pop
and this is my least favorite part
okay well
i think i need to go walk on the
treadmill and drink some fit vine like
bird after that because
that was a lot
i wish i had the other two burgers
because i paid for them but i really am
kind of happy that they weren't there
because
i don't think i could have even made it
past the four burgers now that i think
about
thanks
thanks for watching make sure you follow
joke world on instagram we're sending
everyone free stickers when you do and i
hope you enjoyed the video and i'll see
you next time this podcast is brought to
you by licking your fingers oh my god
why use a napkin
when god gave you one
oh
hey uh
you're not feeling sick are you cause
i'm just started
wash it down with a little kool-aid
with brackets is brought to you by
diabetes
i want mcdonald's right now
[Music]
so
[Music]
you